despite low unemployment figures it's
all go at this central London drop
centre even on an average weekday for
many people short term contracts with
minimum wage have become the new normal
I never took out most of the jobs now
are on short term contracts there's
hardly any long term contracts being
offered anymore by short serve I mean
about two to three months in duration
the lucky ones find a job in one of the
many coffee chains for low pay and no
guarantee of a basic salary
James tripley has his own experience
with zero hours contracts he works as a
doorman at a security company
you don't know maybe until the Monday
morning what hours you working that week
or the Friday before and you can't plan
anything some weeks the only one here
for a few hours over weeks it's like
could be 50 hours plus sue Patel works
in a supermarket although she has
regular hours
she only earns 9 euros an hour it's
hardly enough to live on in an expensive
city like London my wage is completely
those are my rent we survive on my
husband's wages for the rest of what we
have we don't go out for a meal we don't
go to the cinema we don't go anywhere
where it's costing us to get an entrance
fee because we just can't afford it the
British economy is on the mend though in
the past year it grew by almost 3% it's
mostly the rich who are profiting
altogether their income increases by
over a hundred million euros every day
according to the organisation equality
trust they're calling for fair economic
distribution but employers organizations
say the recovery from the UK's financial
crisis is mainly down to the deregulated
job market
zero hours contracts in the UK have
definitely acted is a sort of employment
stabilizer during the downturn and the
fragile recovery
they gave employers the flexibility that
they need in order to respond to demand
or to counter against uncertainty but
employees want to see an end to this
lack of job security because the economy
is finally growing James Tripp Lee's
involved in the Union and is campaigning
against zero hours contracts we need
jobs that pay well our members don't
want to rely on benefits at the moment
millions of people in Britain trapped in
this revolving door of benefits whether
they're in work or out of work 90
percent of new housing benefit claimants
are actually in work and that's because
the ones I was working but it seems all
employers are reluctant to give up their
flexibility even Buckingham Palace has
started handing out zero-hours contracts